[موسيقى]
كان لدينا اجتماع على ما أعتقد
كان في براغ في وارسو لا أعرف
أكثر مع دونالد ترامب الذي كان
النظير الأمريكي ومن أراد
إقناع الأوروبيين بالمشاركة فيها
عملية الحرب ضد العراق
وجاء مع عدد من
صور الأقمار الصناعية التي جعلتنا نمر
كنا مجرد وزراء في الجوار
من الجدول
مع صور الأقمار الصناعية فيها
أظهر في صوره ما لديه
قدمت كمنصات إطلاق
صاروخ
وقول أنه لا بأس لي أن عشرة سيستخدم هذا
هي منصات إطلاق المنزل
التي سوف تستخدم سمعت
كان لدي أصداء لما هم
أراد أن يقول ويظهر
منذ بضعة أيام
و
سألت
للجيش
من أقمارنا الصناعية المستقلة
لالتقاط الصور
اقوى صور العراق ومتى
أطلق ronfel صوره لي أفرجت عنها
الصور التي جاءت من الأقمار الصناعية
الفرنسية والتي أظهرت أنه في الواقع
كانت صوامع القمح
فقط زاوية الصورة
لم يكن بالضبط نفس الشيء
لهذا كتبت لك
التي أظهرها الأمريكيون على ما أعتقد
أن لديهم آخرين ولكن في الكل
الحالات التي أظهرها هناك يعطيها
الانطباع أنه يمكن أن يكون
في الواقع منصة الإطلاق
الصواريخ وواحدة على نفس الشيء بالضبط
نفس المكان الازدراء بشكل مختلف
من خلال أقمارنا الصناعية تبين أنه كان كذلك
شيء مدني بحت
[موسيقى]
كل الاسباب الا ما تقدم
تعتمد بشكل كبير على
الأشياء التي لم تكن صحيحة و
علاوة على ذلك ، أعتقد أن كولن باول الذي
كان وزير الخارجية في ذلك الوقت
اعترف قبل وفاته وعندما كنت
التقيت به منذ أن كنت أنا أيضا
ذهب إلى الولايات المتحدة وشرح
لم يكن الموقف الفرنسي دائما
سهل لكنني ذهبت بالفعل
أخبرهم أنني التقيت به و
كان لدي الشعور بذلك
لم يكن كولين بولويل كليًا
إذا كنت سأقولها في صفقة أخيرًا
لم يكن لديهم نفس الموقف تمامًا
من الرئيس بوش عندما كنت
التقى كان و
إذا كنت تريد في نفس الوقت مثل و
كما قابلت كاندي في
الوقت بإخباره أن يكون حذرًا
خطأ
العراق بلد
متعددة هو مجال مهم ولكن
مع مواقف مختلفة جدا
هناك خطر إنشاء منطقة في النهاية
عدم اليقين الكبير في ذلك الوقت و
رأيت في وقت لاحق أن في dirailles من
ذات يوم أخبرتني أخيرًا أنه ليس لديك
ليس خاطئًا تمامًا في تحليلك
كان إلى حد كبير بعد الحرب ولكن
لقد كان اعترافًا مهمًا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]